in thinking about the future of the
republican party
we've talked about is the future a
return
to the sort of mccain romney wing of the
republican party
is the future a trumpian q anon type
dominated
republican party is it a fractured party
where someone goes off and takes their
toys home meaning
trump leaves the party and starts his
own or more traditional republican
parties leave the
party and start their own and the answer
is we just don't know yet
as we talked about donald trump
announcing at a cpac speech at the end
of february
that he wants republicans not to donate
to the party but to donate to his pac
and he will decide which republicans to
primary because they're bad republicans
and on the other hand uh which
republicans to support basically because
they support donald trump okay
speaking on the debut episode of the
lisa booth
show donald trump was interviewed
and named names as to who
he believes is the future of the
republican party
and it's mostly just people that suck up
to trump i don't think it'll be
surprising to you to hear that
the people that donald trump believes
are the future of the republican party
include
florida governor ron desantis who from
the beginning of the
coronavirus pandemic resisted doing
anything in florida cow towed to trump
placated trump kept as much open for as
long as possible
trump says ron desantis is part of the
future of the republican party
senators josh hawley ted cruz and rand
paul
you'll remember that back in the 2016
republican primary
trump and cruz didn't really get along
cruz saying some ugly things about
trump trump literally implying
that ted cruz's wife is ugly so a lot of
ugly there but ultimately ted cruz came
around to donald trump
uh rand paul major trump brown noser
became a friend of trump's during the
campaign during the presidency playing
golf with trump
josh hawley arguably the most prominent
senator
who on january 6th tried to actually
prevent the electoral votes from being
counted so we know why they are there
south dakota governor christie gnome
she has been a big trump suck-up to some
degree maybe she's on the list because
trump finds her attractive that's always
a possibility with donald trump as well
and then of course arkansas republican
gubernatorial candidate
sarah huckabee sanders a massive trump
suck-up who has importantly remained
loyal after she left the administration
remember that sarah huckabee sanders was
a donald trump's press secretary
for some period of time so these are the
people trump says are the future
he said quote i think we have a lot of
people we have a lot of
young good people ron desantis is doing
a really good job in florida josh hawley
has shown
real courage in going after big tech you
know they go after him
josh is terrific somebody that's been
really terrific as ted cruz trump said
he and i had it out for a while
actually we were very close even during
the campaign
and then it got nasty the press would
say when's the nastiness going to start
i said don't worry it'll start and it
got very violent
but he's been great essentially meaning
eventually ted cruz just uh prayed at
the altar of trump
and then uh trump mentioning a few other
names and saying he's very confident in
the talent pool
calling the republican party stacked
stacked so the the strategy here is very
clear
if trump can be a successful king maker
in 2022
and decide who gets primaried and loses
and decide who he backs who gets
re-elected if he can
effectively pick the winners and losers
in 2022
it better positions him for 2024. he was
asked in this interview
with lisa booth whether whether and when
he will decide
about throwing his hat in the ring he
just didn't say anything about it yet
um and it seems very very clear that if
trump
fails to control the party in 2022 he's
unlikely to run
and i think even if he succeeds he may
not run because he'll just be
uh you know older tired or bored with
the idea
by 2024. if trump successfully
runs the 2022 primary in particular
if the people he chooses help to take
control back of the house or senate from
democrats in 2022
i think at least trump will be able to
make the case that he is still
the most powerful figure in the party
and may run in 2024.
the names on trump's list not hugely
surprising
whether trump will succeed at this in
2022 certainly remains to be seen
one of our sponsors purevpn is giving
you 47
off a one-year plan which comes out to
less than six bucks a month
purevpn makes you anonymous online and
you can trust them they're the only vpn
with an always-on
third-party audit verifying that your
internet activity is not being logged
purevpn keeps you safe from hackers
prevents you from being spied on by your
isp
social media companies government
surveillance it lets you stream
shows and movies that aren't available
in your country
purevpn is super fast with over 6500
servers
and you can use it on all of your
devices with 10
devices logged in at the same time you
can try it for a week
for just 99 cents and you'll get 47
percent off a one year plan
which is less than six bucks a month
when you go to davidpakman.com
vpn the link is under this video and
you'll even get an
extra additional 10
off when you use the code pacman